but first it was a huge day for the
right of self-defense a huge day for due
process a huge day for the presumption
of innocence and a huge day for kyle
rittenhouse who was found not guilty as
we thought he would be on all five
counts take a look
the defendant will rise to face the jury
and hearken to its verdicts
wisconsin versus kyle right house as the
first count of the information joseph
rosenbaum read the jury find the
defendant kyle h rittenhouse not guilty
as to the second count of the
information richard mcginnis we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty as to the third count of the
information unknown mail we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the fourth count of the
information anthony huber we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the fifth count of the information
gage rose croix we the jury find the
defendant kyle edward kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
kyle rittenhouse based on the law based
on the evidence video evidence testimony
is an innocent man he acted in
self-defense this is backed by the video
evidence multiple eyewitness accounts
even the prosecution's star witness
backed this up in court now a jury
unanimously has confirmed what has been
obvious for months that
and that is obvious to everyone acting
in good faith and by the way joe biden
the democratic party the mob in the
media are not acting in good faith and
they have not been the whole time why as
usual they rushed to judgment they never
bothered to review the evidence as per
usual they never reached out to
witnesses as per usual instead well they
do what they always do rush to judgment
then the smears and slander and
besmirchment in this case a 17 year old
now an 18 year old kyle rittenhouse in
order to score
a cheap political win now kyle
rittenhouse should sue them all
all of them starting with joe biden on
the campaign trail he referred to
rittenhouse as a white supremacist who
should be disavowed rittenhouse is not a
white supremacist not a shred of
evidence was ever presented that in any
way suggests that he shot three other
white men who were attacking him now two
of these men were convicted violent
felons one of them served a decade
behind bars why for raping five little
boys ages 9 to 11. rittenhouse was
clearly acting in self-defense the
evidence showed it joe biden owes kyle
rittenhouse an apology that has not been
forthcoming instead joe released a
statement saying he was angry and
concerned by the verdict then he trotted
out to the rose garden pardon the turkey
grinning in grinning year to ear to ear
he doesn't give a rip about kyle
rittenhouse i guess he's turned the page
here like he has in afghanistan and the
hell that he went through by the way
because of the slander the libel from
the left including and starting with joe
biden himself his vice president kamala
harris also trashing the verdict saying
that our justice system needs to be more
equitable just last week member jen sake
asked by our own peter ducey suggesting
that well generally speaking
we don't like vigilantes and another lie
and frankly if i was kyle rittenhouse's
attorney she should be held accountable
as well in 2020 congresswoman presley
called rittenhouse a white supremacist
domestic terrorist drove across state
lines armed with an ar-15 congresswoman
omar uh called him a domestic terrorist
who executed two people bozo beto
o'rourke accused him of being a white
nationalist terrorist two weeks ago
house democratic leader hakeem jeffries
tweeted quote lock kyle written house up
and throw away the key fake news cbs
they falsely reported that rittenhouse
murdered two men msdnc they might be the
worst of the bunch falsely referring to
rittenhouse as a right-wing extremist
nbc news falsely reporting rittenhouse
flashed a white power sign several weeks
before the trial
none of this is true none of it but now
that rittenhouse has been found not
guilty on all charges the smears are
just as bad look at this actual headline
from msdnc quote the kyle rittenhouse
trial was designed to protect white
conservatives who kill meanwhile comrade
de blasio the soon-to-be leaving mayor
of new york city tweeted quote anthony
huber joseph rosenbaum are victims they
should be alive today the only reason
they are not is because a violent
dangerous man chose to take a gun across
state lines and start shooting people to
call this a miscarriage of justice is an
understatement a guy that caught that
took away a billion dollars from funding
the police in new york city wow and not
to be outdone california's governor
newsom tweeting america today you can
break the law carry around weapons built
for a military shoot and kill people and
get away with it that's the message that
we've just sent to armed vigilantes
across the nation jerry nadler called it
a miscarriage of justice that sets a
dangerous precedent congresswoman corey
bush tweeting quote the judge the jury
the defendant it's white supremacy in
action this system isn't built to hold
white supremacists accountable it's why
black and brown folks are brutalized and
put in cages while white supremacist
supremacist murderers walk free the
congressional black caucus they released
a statement it says it is unconscionable
that our justice system would allow an
armed vigilante to go free former backup
quarterback turned social justice
warrior himself colin kaepernick wrote
we just witnessed a system built on
white supremacy validate the terroristic
acts of a white supremacist and this
only further validates the need to
abolish our current system white
supremacy cannot be reformed now when
you think the dishonest rhetoric and the
vitriol can't get any worse guess what
think again take a look
to take from this verdict what they want
and to use it as permission
to attack black lives matter and black
lives matter ain't just black people as
we just saw mr huber and mr rosenbaum
are white they're jewish they are also
victims and easily made victims because
anyone who supports black lives matter
should be very afraid tonight are we
safer after this verdict are we safe if
we let someone like kyle rittenhouse
kill people and then claim self-defense
do we need better laws that protect us
better and the answer is clearly yes
what effect will this case have on
things like vigilantism and self-defense
arguments to be clear the aggregate uh
kind of understanding that we get from
these zimmerman style verdicts that
aggregate message is twofold one it is
to tell the current and future kyle
written houses of the world that they
can engage in white vigilantism i do
believe that age was a factor however i
think that it was amplified by the fact
that he enjoyed the privilege of being
infantilized and i hate to you know in
any way vilified prosecutors they did
what they could with the facts of this
case but the deck was stacked against
him not the least of which the judge in
many ways had their hands tied behind
their backs now my message to kyle
rittenhouse tonight sue them all hold
them all accountable for their lives
make them pay and follow the law and i'd
start with joe biden kyle rittenhouse
did not cross a state line with a weapon
he did not travel to kenosha looking for
a fight instead he was in kenosha as
testimony in the case showed cleaning
graffiti from the prior night's riots he
was then asked to stick around defend a
friend's car dealership he was then
chased he was assaulted he was cornered
by an angry mob now this was a clear-cut
case in every instance of self-defense
now we do not operate under a system of
mob rule truth justice evidence due
process our key components of this great
republic if anyone at fake news cnn
msdnc if they had an ounce of decency
they would tell the truth they would
show the evidence they would apologize
for their buyer's coverage but that's
never going to happen liars their con
otters con artists their democratic race
obsessed political operatives kyle
rittenhouse and americans everywhere we
do deserve better this happens again and
again and again richard jewell cambridge
police ferguson missouri hands up don't
shoot uh freddie gray baltimore maryland
uva duke lacrosse trayvon martin george
zimmerman they're always wrong they
always rush to judgment they never allow
due process they never allow the
presumption of innocence